Pedro Correa, Actor/Filmmaker: He sent me a
voicemail at about three in the morning or
something and was “Pedro…wow…wow.”
Film Courage:
How do you know this is the right path for you?
Pedro: When it's I'm exhausted, this
was last night I was sitting there.
I had started working at 9:30 in the morning which
is so late for an artist let me just say. 9:30 in
the morning I started working. I think it was 1:30
at night I realized I was where am? I didn't think
I was just working and editing and little promos
for the movie and thinking about other script
ideas and doing it all. Those are the moments I'm
reminded where I'm oh I will never do anything
else other than create. I call it time travel
moments where you're just doing 16 hour days and
whether you feel crap or not, you wake up the
next day and do it again. That's how I know.
Film Courage: Do the days tend
to blend in to one another?
Pedro: For sure. If I didn't travel so
much I would I probably still think I'm 19.
I feel it's good seasonal chapters of being
ah when I went to New York that was July.
Film Courage: Would you say
you're obsessed with storytelling?
Pedro: I would I think I'm so
obsessed with storytelling I can't
choose just one specific field
in storytelling and I never will
what makes you obsessed think there's a lot of
adventures in my own life that I think are just
too good not to share I've had a fun I've had
a fun life and whether it's those specific
adventures I think there's moments that can
connect people and me to people that are worth
sharing and I think the coolest part about making
movies is that it's brought me so much closer to
my friends talking about each other's movies or
talking about someone else's movies it's always
a great way to just communicate and relate and and
feel and yeah I've gotten way closer to my family
just by doing this movie and I've changed my mind
about my relationship with my family a million
times throughout this movie and I probably would
have never had those conversations till a day that
me and all of my family are dead I
would have never talked about some
of the stuff that I have because of movies
did they know you were writing the script
with Fabio [Fabio Fey, the director of the film My
Dead Dad] yes yeah yeah so yeah I can't remember
when oh no yeah so Fabio and I were we're talking
about shooting shooting some ideas that could be
doable for us shot several shorts together and
that's some really dumb sketch comedy stuff
that some of it I still think is funny but we were
trying to figure out what resources we could take
in our lives and and make something out of it and
apartments were one of those things so we started
talking about a lot of apartment ideas and Fabio
didn't know it at the time but my dad had had lung
cancer when I was 14 and I think it was 23 or 24
when he started talking about my dad dad maybe 23.
and so he never knew about any of that and I
started talking about oh my dad had lung cancer
he called me I hadn't seen him in
years he was on in Peru I was in Qatar
he had said hey man I was shocked he was
even calling in the first place and was hey
what's up and he's nothing much I'm
dying and I have a month left to live
and I was what and he told me that he had an
apartment in Peru that I had no idea even existed
kind of a shabby crumbly apartment and that
at the time he said your name is going to be
put on it because I'm not going to last much
longer and you're going to have to manage it
and I was 14 totally unqualified I didn't
even know where it was or even really speak
great enough Spanish to manage that and so
luckily in real life he actually had his lung
removed surgically removed he had lung cancer
and survived by a sliver of fate so I went on
for two three months being oh My Dad's
Dead movie I'm an apartment manager now
life was on its head for sure and luckily
throughout that experience later on when I
when I was becoming a little bit more of an
adult I moved to Peru and got to spend a lot
of time with him and sort of get closer in that
way and and so our apartment ideas the low budget
kind of resource filmmaking and that idea sort of
met and yeah it's really special and it's weird
because people usually think my dad's dead
rightfully so but he's actually still alive
he's actually still alive we don't really
communicate in a traditional way as often and he's
a thick Peruvian accent he lives in another world
for sure but he actually saw the movie a month ago
he knew I was making a movie I don't think
he knew exactly that it was kind of greatly
inspired by him and and I kind of mentioned it
it brought us closer together I think there was
a lot of he sent me a voicemail about three in
the morning or something was “Pedro…wow…wow.”
so I love you wow it's just it's the greatest
voice memo ever and yeah I'm sure we'll talk about
it more that's awesome yeah yeah because some
people might be you're talking about family things
and maybe it's too close for them to see and
yeah so that's that's awesome that you had that
experience that was a cool moment for sure
did you envision yourself as this manager
yeah it's I can't even manage myself I still
can't let alone an apartment my lord yeah nope
I would love to see a 14 year old coming to
collect late rent yeah that'd be awesome good
luck with that yeah not sure how well that would
go over but right yeah I think I think too just to
add on to that making movies that that are kind
of personal in that way the cool thing about it
is that they can mean so much more as time goes on
I look back at some of the movie and I'm oh that
that's a line I wrote or something where
I'm oh changed my mind about that but
that movie's gonna be really special I think
in five years and in 10 years and 20 years
and I can't wait to show my kids one day that
movie or my sister my I don't think my sister's
seen the movie yet she's 19 and was even kind
of I think more distant from my dad at the time
because they got divorced when I was young so she
was really young and I can't wait till she sees it
and I don't know if she'll totally get it but
watch it marietta did she live in Qatar with you
she yeah she lived in Qatar with me so we were
in Seattle she was born in Seattle then me and my
sister my mom and step-dad actually moved to Qatar
and then I split up from them and moved to Peru
halfway through high school and then yeah
then my sister moved to Germany with my mom
and then china with my mom and now my mom's in
Brazil she's a teacher and just gets all these
cool opportunities to teach across the world so
that's how I kind of got roped into the world
very cool yeah you said that you had so many
fun experiences that you wanted to share them
in stories is there someone's life that you
look at where you've watched their biopic
and you think wow Hunter S. Thompson or somebody
where you're just if I could have lived that life
may or may not have been good who knows but yeah
I mean what's so funny about that I've sort of I'm
starting to change my perspective on this and we
talked about this a little bit with Seattle and
these great artists that may have not stuck
around because of whatever reason drugs or
or just themselves and I think it's funny
because immediately when you say that
most of the people I'm I look up to are dead
which is crazy prematurely like heath ledger or
I mean Kurt Cobain for various reasons
which is just so interesting that I think
I don't know if this is everyone but I know a lot
of young people who idolize people who've died
young and maybe there's they kind of I think I
was vicariously living through their wild life and
and and the fact that they're great artists like
heath ledger for example there's a documentary I
think it's called I am heath I should know the
title because I've seen it 20 times literally
I went through a phase where I was just on and
I was writing just constantly so I don't know
why that is and I think there's something to that
it's almost weird just about humans but the older
I get the more I realize there's definitely
a balance and I think it's almost kind of
a little questionable to to blindly I mean idolize
anyone but let alone these bright burning souls
without really asking yourself damn is
everything that they've gone through
worth living that I don't know
yeah I remember when I turned 27 someone said
I hope you don't join the 27 club and I kind of
went down this rabbit hole of researching and I
was oh wow I mean Janice Joplin so many different
people Amy Winehouse at that time she wasn't
famous but just different people and you go you
it's easy to see their life as I don't even know
the word for it it's tragic and it's beautiful
but at the same time yeah it's very sad yeah no
it's very rockstar-esque and I mean even myself
just maybe this is the Seattle in me or or the
crazy experiences I've gone through there was
definitely probably from the age of 19 to maybe
22. I was yeah kind of saying it jokingly but yeah
i'll probably be part of the 27 club or whatever
why would I say that that's horrible yeah and
now I'm 26 so I'm oh god no oh no oh my gosh why
did I bring this up I'm sorry this is weird that
we went here okay no no no it's interesting to me
it's it's so weird right I mean so it's important
but I said it's important to look at the the
positive in those people's lives and also like
like how they feel and what what was wrong in
those moments too because everyone goes through it
everyone thinks about crazy stuff that the 27
club or or dying young or any of that and I
think that's why art's so cool because it just
breaks through a lot of that and forces you to
talk about it that's why I think it's one
of the most important things on the planet
sure and but the thing is it it seems cool because
there's this legacy but not everybody's going to
be Jim Morrison and your life is done yeah yeah
and so and I think we get easily seduced by that
right right it's yeah and I say
it jokingly but I'm I haven't
done that much stuff that wouldn't
be good but I mean like yeah it's no
no I think living a long and wise life is
very underrated for sure for sure yeah.
How do you know if you’re an artist?